les Journées Mondiales de la Jeunesse
célébrait chaque année elle prenne une
envergure toute particulière tous les
deux trois ans puisqu'à l'invitation du
pape un grand rassemblement est organisé
en 2013 du 23 au 28 juillet ce sera au
Brésil à Rio après Madrid en 2011
plusieurs centaines de milliers de
catholiques sont attendus et on
retrouvera sur place des représentants
de la paroisse des longs courts Maurepas
bonsoir à tous les deux à Sylviane
Nicole et à Gaëlle j'espère donc tous
les deux membres de cette paroisse
d'Élancourt Maurepas on va parler des
événements que vous allez organiser
parce que le but pour vous et c'est
aussi pour ça que vous êtes ici ce soir
c'est de récolter des fonds pour
financer votre voyage vous souhaitez
vous y rendre mais tout d'abord ça
représente quoi c'est JMJ pour vous
JMJ pour nous je pense que c'est un
grand temps de rencontre un grand temps
de partage avec des jeunes catholiques
du monde entier nous sommes nous sommes
appelés par le par le pape à se
rassembler donc comme vous l'avez dit
tous les deux à trois ans et c'est je
pense extrêmement important pour les
jeunes catholiques nous qui avons
parfois du mal à tous nous retrouver
ensemble de se rassembler de pouvoir de
de pouvoir prier ensemble vous êtes
plusieurs milliers centaines de milliers
à être présents comme encore à Madrid en
2011 vous avez déjà participé à des JMJ
on a fait les JMJ de Madrid 2011
justement quel souvenir vous en gardez
alors de cette période de ce moment de
réunion de communion
un moment festif un moment où on
rencontre des jeunes qu'on n'aurait
jamais rencontré si on n'était pas allé
on mélange les on mélange les cultures
on mélange les façons de vivre et les
façons de vivre sa foi qui sont pas que
de religion uniquement de la façon dont
on pratique ça fera que de religion on
parle aussi beaucoup de enfin on fait un
échange culturel aussi on voit comment
les gens là-bas ils ont ils vivent
chose qu'on n'a pas faim qu'on voit pas
forcément de là où on est en France on
n'a pas la vue la visibilité de ce que
eux peuvent vivre au quotidien
ce serait une quinzaine de votre
paroisse à vous y rendre pour le pour
durant cet été ce sera les premières JMJ
du pape François vous en attendez quoi
comme comme chaque pape est différente
de grandes choses en tant que vous avez
des attentes particulières des des
symboles qui pourraient ou des choses
qui pourraient être dites qui qui
trancherait avec ce qui avait été fait
jusqu'à maintenant je pense que tous les
papes sont dans une droite ligne depuis
plus de 2000 ans donc il ne faut pas
s'attendre avec avec ce nouveau pape des
changements énormes dans l'église mais
peut-être une ouverture qui est qui est
grâce à ce pape beaucoup plus vers la
pauvreté même s'il est glisse fait déjà
beaucoup beaucoup pour les pauvres nous
allons aussi au gym Jr Rio pas
uniquement pour loisir en cours prière
mais nous nous rendons aussi là-bas pour
faire de l'aide auprès de jeunes nous
avons différentes actions qui seront
prévues
de comment d'aide d'aide auprès de
jeunes défavorisés de jeunes orphelins
dans le nord du Brésil dans le nord du
Brésil je vais juste vous faire réagir
sur un chiffre parce que ça fait aussi
partie de l'actualité et ça n'a été
beaucoup question en 2011 à Madrid du
coup du déplacement du pape là pour
cette année ce sera 59 millions de
dollars c'est le coût de cette visite
donc du pape au Brésil est-ce que c'est
un chiffre qui vous choque ou pas cet
argent soit mis pour déplacer pour
organiser ce rendez-vous nous avions
parlé énormément du coût du prix du de
l'arrivée du pape à Madrid c'était une
vingtaine de millions à l'époque il faut
savoir que nous venions quand même il y
a eu 2 millions de personnes décomptées
lors du grand rassemblement donc ça fait
10 euros par personne de dépensé à
Madrid pour pouvoir pour pouvoir
réinjecter dans l'économie locale cet
argent je pense que ça a été retombé sur
les populations locales le Brésil va en
bénéficier d'après vous oui tout à fait
le fait de faire venir des jeunes du
monde entier boost
vous allez organiser des rendez-vous qui
permettront de collecter des fonds
puisque le billet pour Rio reste à votre
à votre charge vous aider par exemple
l'association une association à
l'organisation de représentations de
théâtre c'est le club de théâtre des
élèves de saint-contins en Yvelines de
Saint-François d'Assise à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux plus précisément
que vous aider vous pouvez nous en dire
un petit peu plus alors en fait c'est
la troupe Astra balthéâtre qui s'est
proposé pour nous aider à financer notre
voyage
en juin les deux représentations du mois
de juin au profit de
djmj pour la paroisse et l'encours
Maurepas
cette
troupe de théâtre depuis 2008
initie les jeunes du collège de
Saint-François d'Assise
au monde du théâtre donc que ça soit que
ça soit
faire un jeu d'acteur ou faire une mise
en scène
il travaille beaucoup là-dessus et cette
troupe de théâtre a aussi une troupe
d'adultes et c'est cette troupe
d'adultes là qui qui s'est mis au
service de notre de notre action les
représentations 29 et 30 juin date et
horaire qui vont s'afficher de l'atelier
de Grimbert ce sera ça vous permettra de
récupérer des fonds pour financer notre
voyage financer votre voyage
c'est-à-dire que l'entrée est payante il
y a des l'entrée est payante elle est
entre 5 7 et 10 euros en suivant les
envies des personnes qui viendront
sur place il y a une garderie parce
qu'on sait que les parents c'est pas
forcément facile
de s'organiser penser à tout pour
pouvoir récupérer des fonds sur
l'ensemble des petits détails qui
peuvent effectivement faciliter la vie
des familles on est un petit peu pris
par le temps alors je vais juste un
petit peu accélérer puisque il y aura
d'autres rendez-vous aussi qui seront
organisés vous participez au fait de la
musique pour récolter là aussi des fonds
tout à fait nous faisons un concert pour
lors de la fête de la musique un concert
qui ne sera pas uniquement catholique
qui sera aussi pour les églises
protestantes avec avec lesquelles nous
avons pas mal de relations et ce concert
aura lieu donc le 21 le 21 juin au soir
au temple au temple protestant du Gandou
l'atelier de grand-mère pour l'instant
c'est là où il faut vous rendre si vous
souhaitez aider ces jeunes de la
paroisse des longs courts pas à financer
leur billet et donc pour Rio pour les
prochaines JMJ représentation 29 juin et
30 juin au théâtre du collège
Saint-François d'Assise à Montigny le
Bretonneux merci à tous les deux
j'espère que vous ignorez les fonds pour
partir mais j'imagine que vous allez
partir que vous ayez ou non réussi à
lever à lever suffisamment de fonds
merci à